all right so we were just watching the
president of the united states dr fauci
stepped in for for one quick
uh answer there but for the most part uh
the people in the room were asking
questions that many of us were thinking
about i want to welcome i'd already
talked about kaylee and emily because we
we got into that with the president but
just to welcome fox and friends first
co-host carly shimkus we can't throw
enough love at her she's new on that
program she's rocking back
just rocking it
and the center virtual seat for us today
of course we've got a doctor the doctor
fox news contributor and professor of
medicine at nyu langone medical center
dr mark siegel all right you're on the
hot seat now doctor
uh i want to know about when when the
president says
that he is doing what he's doing to slow
things down um and that he took a quick
action
to be able to give us a gap in which to
inoculate people two questions
fauci said well we can test for the
variant you can't test for the variant
at the airport right just like you
couldn't test for the delta variant at
the airport let's start there so how is
that actually protecting us
well i want to go into the science of
this harris for a minute rapid testing
is going to be effective at picking this
up as it is with all the variants what
dr fauci was referring to is there's a
characteristic that this variant has
when it hits against a pcr test that
allows you to identify it it's called an
s gene dropout just to be very technical
at the airport so we can use a pc
no and that's your point no not at the
airport so we're not going to be able to
screen for this at the airport and say
uh oh here comes the variant that's
number one number two people can slip in
through intermediate countries and you
know take the training from south africa
take a train and then get in and the
third thing is this is putting a lot of
attention on south africa when they're
actually the country that identified
this and has already sequenced it and
did the world a big favor here and
fourth point and last point the w.h.o as
usual asleep at the switch here by the
time we hear about it it's already all
around the world and for sure it's here
in the united states well and dr mccary
last hour said that we've known since
potentially november 10th we we had a
whole holiday season we could have
protected people from if travel bans
were going to work really quick just a
last one and then kaylee and emily will
take it away
so
we we know that it's coming it's already
here on the continent it's in canada and
conceivably if you've got people from
like south africa and the u.s virgin
islands which we know they opened up to
south africa a few weeks ago less than
two weeks ago whatever the number is
there it was recent right so we know on
this continent whether contiguous or not
near us
we we potentially have it in the united
states in short order whatever that day
hour is going to be so how is this
different than anything else we'd study
why not use those bsl level floor labs
the 59 around the world the four that
are here you've been to one of those bio
containments write live on fox news and
figure out whether or not the vaccines
work against this in less than 24 hours
yeah absolutely that should be done
they're already starting to do that work
in south africa and with modern and
pfizer but it should be sped up we
should know that right away my
prediction on that is that
like today and my prediction on that by
the way is that the vaccines will work
and they may not be as effective but the
vaccine plus the booster should be
sufficient i'll tell you why real
quickly because 95
of the spiked protein is not involved in
these mutations we use the word
mutations it scares the heck out of
everybody but 95 is the same the
vaccines are going to offer some
protection for sure but we need to know
about that yesterday you're right
yeah um look dr siegel so dr fauci was
asked about this potential travel ban
and we'll get to the hypocrisy of all
that and the things that they said about
trump's travel ban in a moment but dr
falci was asked specifically hours
before this travel ban came down whether
it should be in place and he essentially
said that it's premature we need more
data
and then the travel bans come but they
announced that they're not going to be
put in place till monday as if covid19
takes a holiday weekend break while
other european countries did these
travel bans expeditiously and
immediately should we have followed in
the steps of europe here
yeah of course we should have done this
already and you knew that this was
political i was thinking this over the
weekend definition of politics takes
place on monday how can you possibly
rationalize that from a scientific point
of view here's how i look at it the sick
horses are out of the barn and now you
quarantine the barn with no horses left
in the barn that's what we're doing here
pure politics
dr siegel we just listened to the
president say as well a little minute
ago a few minutes ago if you're worried
about the variant he says get your
booster he said if you're worried about
covid get your vaccination shot now you
just described to us why the vaccination
would be why the vaccine would be
effective against this new variant
because of the 95 percent so why the
travel ban then if someone is just
coming to the table right now can you
break down in simple terms why a travel
ban is needed if the vaccine and the
booster is so effective against any
variant that these countries including
ours identify
well that's a great question we don't
know for sure the degree to which the
vaccine is effective but i don't agree
with the president's point that we need
a slowdown here while we find out
because you know what happens we spread
fear we cause economic consequences we
cause depression more anxiety everybody
flashes back almost two years and it's
really cruel and unnecessary and not
from a public health point of view i
don't think it adds anything and i don't
agree with the point about south africa
either south africa feels targeted here
and other countries are not going to go
ponying up their variants if they think
they're going to get crushed
economically as a result that was the
reporter from bloomberg asked the first
question and that was whether or not
other countries are now not going to
report variants because they've seen the
way the united states and just a few
other countries the uk have banned
together and said well you know what if
you're coming from there well look they
did the hard work and in fact they have
some details already on this variant
they're not being widely reported
but they're coming and the president
there says he feels punished and those
other african nations say we feel
punished because
we reported to you what was going on and
then you closed basically your borders
to us and by the way there's a big hunk
and border that's open i could go on
i could go on carly i'm coming right to
you i want to get to this though kaylee
touched on it and it has to do with what
president biden has said about bans in
the past
and you know when you look at it do we
have i'm going to ask the team if we
have some of that so we can just hear it
from the president's own words do we
have it
let's watch
okay they don't carly as you'll recall
the president
caught then candidate joe biden called
president trump xenophobic now we knew
that the virus was in fact coming from
china so it wasn't a guess
it wasn't any of that kind of thing
these were first steps as dr siegel just
pointed out those were 2019 moves we're
in 2021 now your thoughts yeah and i
believe that president biden also posted
a tweet criticizing former president
trump for a ban on african countries
calling it um calling it racist and and
look at where we are right now
my big takeaway with all of this with
the information that we know right now
is is that the reaction to it doesn't
match um what we're hearing especially
from the south african doctor who first
alerted the world um to this uh variant
she says that she's seeing mild symptoms
all like sore muscles tiredness for a
day or two not feeling well
they might have a slight cough so we're
shutting down travel
we're getting uh global hysteria over
this in a presidential press conference
where the president of the united states
just said that we're facing a new threat
is it a new threat or is it an extension
of the old threat that might be
less severe than other variants that
we've already seen and then harris in
new york you have governor kathy hokel
declaring a state of emergency we're in
a state of emergency right now
for the possibility of of something that
could maybe come down the road and the
reaction to this is always the same you
have people on the left who now then
live in fear and folks on the right who
just tune it out and say i don't trust
you anymore this is an overreaction and
neither of those things are good i think
that the better course of action would
be to react to the information that we
already have
react accordingly and also no matter
what happens with this variant we have
to learn to live with this virus we're
two years in at this point gotta learn
to live with it no matter what yeah you
know it's such a great point and um the
audience saw me go like this because i
really wanted to get to uh president
biden so so let's do that but but let's
take it in this direction
president biden was calling for
americans to wear mask indoors just a
moment ago when when he talked to the
nation
let's watch
as additional protections please wear
your mask when you're indoors
in public settings around other people
it protects you and protects those
around you
unless you're partying like it's 1999 on
the island of nantucket
president biden spotted in nantucket
shopping indoors without a mask despite
a sign right there mandating it
you got to wear a mask but
so you know here's the thing and i'm
going to kind of i'll go back to you dr
siegel because i really want to
understand where we are right now
we have the delta variant
we we've got omicron is if it's not
already here it's on its way because
people are hopping on planes so on and
so forth what again are the best things
that we can do to protect ourselves
because it doesn't seem like the white
house is capable of just starting there
and being consistent
you know i think that
taking making sure you're fully
vaccinated or having a booster or
counting your own
natural immunity from covet as part of
this those are things how much immunity
do you have against the virus number one
i agree with the point that it may end
up being quite mild and we should
congratulate south africa for the great
work they've done the other thing that
needs to happen thank them the other
thing that needs to happen here and no
one is talking about this is that you
had a tremendous operation warp speed
under the trump administration as kaylee
knows got these vaccines at record time
but we haven't matched that with rapid
testing the biden administration has
been asleep at the switch here with this
we should have rapid tests in every
house in america provided by the
government
with a public-private partnership so
that if you're in contact with covet you
can test yourself and know before you go
out of the house and spread it elsewhere
it's so simple and it hasn't been done
kaylee i know you have thoughts on the
mask yeah what is he doing i mean i was
asked ad nauseam about president trump
anytime he did not wear a mask and
follow-ups and aggressive reporters and
where was the question from the press of
president biden you just said wear a
mask why weren't you doing so on
nantucket that was irresponsible in my
view for that question not to be asked
but at the end of the day no one has
politicized this virus more than
president joe biden you have the mask
worrying incident there you have kamalas
saying on the campaign trail if donald
trump tells me to take the vaccine i
won't take it you had biden mimicking
that rhetoric then they get into office
yay take the vaccine that should have
been the message back on the campaign
trail as well on travel restrictions you
know trump's xenophobic for this and now
all of a sudden travel restrictions work
are you sensing a pattern here because
you should it is politicization of this
virus on the campaign trail they
dismissed the policies they eschewed the
policies they are now putting in place
they were always effective uh and there
where's the consistency rather than
outright politicization of covet 19.
well you know they say they're going to
follow the science and dr fauci was
there and they're they're having to kind
of back up the decisions that they've
made which by the way according to dr
siegel and i don't want to paraphrase
you incorrectly doctor but they're going
to have to do something like a reversal
sooner or later because it's going to be
here and and what do we do do we just
lock ourselves off they're not going to
put travel bans across america are they
oh my gosh
i mean from your lips to the
government's ears i have to say be be
careful what you utter um i guess we're
all going to florida because that's
where the case number
and i think uh to your point one of the
most interesting things uh in terms of
the politicization was dr fauci's
answers on his interview this this in
the in the past recent days when he said
i am science and essentially equating
criticism of him with criticism of
science so it's once again forcing
people into a their self-designated box
that when they say i stand for science
we know what that implies which is that
someone who dares criticize him does not
and when someone brought up well what
about the the accusations of being
untruth staying untruths before congress
he brought up in response well what
about january 6th so in terms of the
overt politicization from the mouths of
those representing this government none
more than dr fauci himself wow i am
science like senator cory booker of new
jersey said that day i'm sorry
exactly yes
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now